hello everyone and welcome to another
super exciting game from the extra con
open its a vice rally again and here she
takes on the Swedish Grandmaster Johnny
Hector who is not only a grandmaster but
also a grandmaster in correspondence
just so quite an obstacle for the young
player and like it's again from the
final round so it would really mean a
lot for both of them of course to win it
but I don't want to spoil too much for
you let's just enjoy the game as it's
really crazy and also I would just like
to invite everyone to choose base
India's channel chakra shot from Jays
base India conducted an interview with
pregnant on the end device Charlie so to
check it out it will be the first link
in the description below you know if you
just want to enjoy that as well maybe
after checking out this video if you
don't want to spoil too much but you
know either way is fine so getting back
to the game Jonny Hector and known for
his aggressive style goes for efore but
Charlie goes for c5 the Sicilian defense
is on the board with Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 and sorry about that
not Knight the c3 waiting still still
waiting with the d4 checking out what
black will play also a useful move if
you want to maybe try and confuse black
a little maybe black decides to go for a
5 and doesn't even allow d4 you know a
lot of things can happen here but now
have I probably ignores him we have d6
and now we transpose into the mainline
the fort we've seen captures Knight
captures and Knight to f6 now and now
Bishop to g5 by actor-director rouser a
variation of the Sicilian with e 6
bye-bye Charlie and Queen to d2
Hector prepares a queenside castle with
a6 preparing well b5 and B for Hector
castles here and we have best of the e7
there should be seven the main line here
over 5,000 games in the database with
Bishop to d7 also Vasily when she played
it against Parham oxalá well MacDougall
had the black pieces in that game in the
lien masters that finished recently I'm
ashamed of not covering their game but I
will at some point but Bishop to e7 here
and now f4 and okay Bishop to d7 now we
have Knight to f3 not allowing
this exchange you don't want to allow
black to capture on d4 and then get the
bishop over to c6 you want to make black
work for it
and b5 now preparing b4 with Bishop
captures an f6 G captures an f6 Bishop
captures also possible but last time it
was played it was in 2007 and now in the
era of engines and players are no longer
afraid to you know ruin any porn
structures with King 2b one always a
useful move if the position opens up you
don't want your well Queen and King on
the same diagonal and also at some point
this queen is coming to a5 so you want
the King to be ready to defend the DA to
pawn here we have Queen to b6 still this
is all a standard theory of this line
this is the main move here and now we
have Bishop to d3 main idea for white is
a5 but Johnny have to prepared something
in different with Bishop to d3 and now
before kicking the knight back with
Knight to e2 now
a5 just defending the before pawn but
also preparing a 4 and perhaps b3 in
some lines Hector no longer waits we
have f5 here the idea is and now of
course just challenging this pawn here
if you capture then you know Knight f4
it's pretty deadly this night is coming
to d5 and then the position plays itself
it's a a common idea in a lot of lines
of the Sicilian so after f5 with a 4 and
now comes Knight to f4 here a Hector's
idea is that he now has a double attack
against the e6 pawn and he wants to go
Bishop to c4 to create a triple attack
here so what do you do
Queen to c5 first not allowing Bishop to
c4 very nice bye-bye charlie and now
this is the position where the game
actually begins because this position
has been reached many times before and a
lot of moves haven't played here rook H
the e1 has been played here F captures
an e6 has been played here Knight h5 has
been played here for example Bobby
Fischer played Bishop no Bobby Fischer
played rook the c1 against Boris Spassky
in game 18 of their World Chess
Championship match in Reykjavik Iceland
for example in 1972 in 1976 Anatoly
Karpov against the Entenmann's played
Bishop to e2 and you
be sure that Fisher knew that Karpov
knew all of Fisher's games so Karpov
obviously thought the Bishop d2 was an
improvement and Fischer's roof to see
one but today in the era of engines
Hector is already with the one of the
engines recommendations rooked rock h2
f1 and this is a new move in this
position and now why Charlie has to deal
with the new move so what do you play
here obviously every every one of us
wants to play b3 if v3 works when I play
b3 and it's a very hard to calculate all
of it out for example if b3 c captures
eight captures white of course will
defend with a three so what do you play
now as some sort of a sacrificial attack
would be very nice but how do you get
how do you get the pieces into it for
example you could try castles with the
idea of sacrificing the rook and maybe
bringing the other Luke over here but
white is just faster here not h5 and now
after rook captures here white ignores
you Queen to h6 threatening mate here
and now you could try rook e1 check King
captures and now for example Queen a5
check King we want you can try a queen a
queen a to check King here and now after
this check butcher blocks and you are
out of options you're getting checkmated
here on the other hand after King
captures and a want you could try rook a
to check first and create you know a
defense with the bishop to f8 but still
doesn't work rugby one and now if you
try Bishop to f8 you're getting made it
here Knight captures f6 King h8 and
Queen captures here so it's not all that
difficult but you still have to
calculate it so I have two rook to h1 if
I Charlie goes for not B 3 but a 3 I
create some weaknesses on the dark
squares around the White King with b3
and now comes Knight to e5 so Bishop to
e2 not allowing this capture that happen
with Knight captures an f3 rook captures
an f3 and now Queen to e5 challenging
the e4 pawn but also threatening mate on
b2 so Knight to b3 attack is the queen
and defends maid and here if I Charlie
doesn't grab the pawn so Queen captures
here would be met with F captures on e6
and after F captures rook here would go
after the be for pawn so if I Charlie
shows that she is not a pawn grabber she
goes a queen to d4 and now comes F
captures on e6 with F captures on e6 and
now
so really a mystery why why Johnny
Hector didn't just go for the pawn here
for example Queen captures Queen
captures the night before captures gets
white into this position where he's up
upon yes black has the bishop pair but
white gets to enjoy the extra pawn
instead he goes rook to f4 first and
allows vice Charlotte to consolidate she
pushes 'if I've now attacks the rook and
now first Bishop to h5 check with King
to d8 and now Queen to f2 forcing the
Queen to move away as this is really
annoying to have to constantly keep an
eye on this b2 squared also of course
you can have captured the rook because
the Queen on d4 would be hanging so here
we have a queen trade Queen captures
rook captures and now rook to b8 just
defending that b4 pawn so here instead
of that endgame where Hector could have
been up upon he has this endgame where
he's not up a pawn but he still faces
the bishop pair so Bishop the f7 by
Hector and now Bishop to c6
a very strong Bishop now we have rook to
e1 guarding d4 pawn and now h5 preparing
h4 with Bishop to e6 h4 and now came to
see one now both players will try to
activate the King as much as possible
with King to e8 King to d2 and now
Bishop to d8 now trying to get this
Bishop to a more useful than diagonal
with Luke to f3 and now kink the e7
attacking the bishop with Bishop back to
c4 and now rook to h6 just putting
another defender here we've looked to e
2 also white improves the position and
now Bishop to a5
you want to defend the b4 pawn so now
the rook from b8 can move we have a g4
by white either saying I'm now going to
have a nice pawn on g4 or you will trade
here with a V on Poisson wife Rawley
captures here with H captors and g3
rook captures and g3 and now rook to h7
not allowing this nice rook lift with
rook to g7 trick with Knights the e1
preparing Knight to f3 to defend the h2
pawn which white will have to do we have
rook to e8 doubling at the H file and
now Knight to f3 just defending and a
rock to h3 here of I Charlie wants to
get rid of
rooks as the rockin Ito isn't doing all
that much so that's up to d5 now and now
a trade route captures with H captures
Bishop captures on d5 e captures on d5
and now Bishop to b6 and this is where
it gets really interesting here rook to
e4 is a move a hectare plate but roopa
rook here doesn't really work
he was probably expecting something like
Bishop to c5 where this bishop just
turns into a pawn but if I Charlie
played a much better move here or we
could say it's sort of a winning move
but feel free to pause the video and try
to find this elusive idea well I give
you a couple of seconds for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent pusher of pawns and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
f5 here the placement the rock on e4
just allowed black to start you know
rolling out those pawns and capturing
and before was never really a threat
because if you capture a Bishop a5 wins
the game you just lose the rook
so here Hector has to find a nice square
for the rookie played c4 and now we have
efore pushing the phones even further
the knight is under attack we have
Knights to age for attacking this pawn
here and just were also threatening ig6
check with the nice fork so King defense
into f6 and now King t2 we have looked
the g8 threatening the capture here and
now rook captures on b4 not a problem to
be temporarily down upon Bishop to c5
forces the rook to move rook c4 and only
now rook captures and g3 so now you can
see white controls a lot of a lot of
space here in front of the White King
sorry black controls a lot of square in
front of the White King and the bishop
here is much stronger than the night so
here we have B for pushing the best row
back Bishop to e7 and now rook to c7
again challenging the bishop bishop back
to d4 route back to c4 with russia back
to G 1 and now Kings to f1 not allowing
this roof to move anywhere as the bishop
has to be protected we have King Teti 5
now preparing Bishop to b4 as you don't
want your rook constantly being there
guarding the bishop we have ripped the
c8 and now Bishop back to be 4 so now
black cannon time
looked f8 threatening the capture on f5
which would be very important
unfortunate rocket racer would be made
so rook to g5 you have to defend mate
and now c4 so here white already has a
very dangerous pawn structure here if he
starts pushing them could get very
dangerous King to f4 and okay we have c5
trying to create a passed pawn and here
is a where why Sharlee doesn't play the
the most precise in the most precise way
here she captured allowing the the
immediate push of the D pawn the correct
idea is Ruby 1 check and after king te 2
looked a 1 and now you ignore white for
example if Knight captures an f5 you
just play rook captures an a2 with check
King e1 and now Bishop to c3 check let's
say King f1 and now you start pushing
this point you can move the rook you can
put this pawn and white it doesn't have
any any decent discoveries so this was
one way to go about it but okay she you
know both players were very low on the
clock she played D captures on c5 and
now Hector gets a new life out of the
position he pushes these six already
that's a very dangerous past pawn C
capture Sun before and now d7 so what do
you do here Bishop to b6 you have to
guard this square here and now first
night the G to check with King to g3 and
now comes look rook to b8 attacking the
bishop here you could also promote right
sorry
not her rook wasn't there you could also
promote and adjust you know when the
bishop button black this is what my
Charlotte is hoping for as the four
points against the one would be would be
hard to play against so here we have not
that but rook to b8 challenging the
bishop with Bishop to c7 and now rook
the c8 so here Hector says I'm just
gonna harass your Bishop and I'm content
with a draw here Bishop to a5
with rook to e8 Bishop back to c7 loop
the c8 Bishop back to a5 and now rook to
e8 we have Bishop the c7 rook the c8 and
here of I Holly if she repeats it will
be a drawback three-fold repetition but
here he says I'm here to play some real
chess and plays f4 so you know when the
is taking you know a bishop is just a
piece and here she just offers it and
prepares to push her path bones so
there's no other way but to capture
leadership we have rope captures and now
rope the d5 first prevented the white
pawn from queening and now probably
rugby 7 with the idea of just capturing
here is best for white but Hector went
for a different line we have haunted the
eight Queen preparing rook to g7 check
we have rook captures roof g7 check King
to f3 and now Knights the e1 check with
King to e3
Knights the CT check and now King to D 2
and here you could capture the before
fun but then III is coming and black is
winning here so Hector tried roof to G
to check with King to c3 and now Knights
the e1 so what do you play here in Vice
Charlie plays look to d2 just
challenging the rook this capture would
be of course winning from black there
are too many points the night will be
helpless you can go an IG - but then b3
is coming pawn captures a - you can stop
the queening of the of the a pawn so
rook to g4 was played but now b3
nonetheless and it was in this position
unmoved 72 that Swedish Grandmaster in
both you know traditional and
correspondence just Johnny Hector
resigned the game and the brilliant
victory for for 18 year old white Rowley
in the final round of the extra Khan
open really just insane the idea is the
same if punk if you don't capture just
you know you put the pond to victory if
you capture a 2 and you cannot prevent
the queening of the pawn if ro G 3 you
can just go King B 2 and there are no
threats here I mean you will Queen the
pawn if Knight check you can just pick
it up and you know still just Queen da
porn so like I said after B 3 Johnny
Hector resigned and this win meant a lot
for y Charlie
she didn't only get her international
master norm in this tournament but she
also got her Grand Master an orphan in
this tournament as she finished with 7
and a half out of 10
her brother pregnenolone de finished
with eight and a half out of ten so he
was the sole leader the winner of the
extra con open but she finished in 16th
place
which sounds you know not a lot but it's
really insane out of 363 players I
believe she finishes with seven out of
seven and a half out of ten and some of
the players that finished with seven and
a half out of ten include top seeds
Neal's given their aunt encore above
daniel booko to row and some other very
strong names like a young Ludovic hammer
I think Morley Karthikeyan also finished
with seven out of seven and a half
Subramanya and finished with seven and a
half and a lot of a lot a very strong
grandmaster so this is just an insane
achievement for for young by Charlotte
here sir I really enjoyed this game and
I really enjoyed the fighting spirit in
this game really just everything about
this game was awesome
at least to me so I hope you enjoyed it
as well and the like I said do check out
the interview by Chaka shock with
partner Honda and vice Charlie it will
be the first link in the description
below you know to check it out and you
know hear their perspective and you know
see their happiness on such a great
achievement really India's golden duo at
the moment so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
David Gill share or a Brad Bird [ __ ]
[ __ ] and Ian McAra for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you all for watching I
will see you soon with some more
hopefully interesting content you know
how it goes so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an ex excellent start
of your week